un spectacle équestre à chambord quoi de
plus normal françois 1er grand amateur
de chasse l'était aussi de chevaux et
aujourd'hui les chevaux sont présents
partout dans le parc avec les
patrouilles de gendarmerie et aux
écuries du maréchal de saxe où oeuvrent
la troupe de frédéric s'amarrera
celui-là il s'appelle mboso il a six ans
c'est sa première saison et il est on en
est vraiment très content il a beaucoup
d'énergie dégage dégage quelque chose de
vraiment vraiment magnifique et ils se
prennent le chemin à tous les jeux de
mots c'est soit la voltige ses toiles et
ça ne m'a pas que ce soit tout ça il et
il promet qu'il est très prometteur une
douzaine de chevaux vite ici à demeure
pour participer aux deux représentations
quotidiennes
les cavaliers sont tous des cascadeurs
comédiens rompus aux figures de haute
école dans les coulisses derniers
réglages avant le spectacle surprise et
prennent et qui c'est qui fait la
percussion thème renaissance
contemporain c'est un peu la première
fois qu'on met les pieds dans ce domaine
aussi on l'a fait pour des tableaux mais
pas pour des spectacles complets
donc c'est un peu une nouvelle pour nous
et locaux et sur un texte de gonzague
saint-bris c'est toute l'histoire de
chambord qui défilent
et très très agréable on a passé un bon
moment et c'est vrai que c'est un très
joli spectacle pour vous les choix ça
fait partie du charme ans il a fait
partie de chambord exceptionnel vraiment
des chevaux merveilleux et quel
spectacle vraiment sensations on a passé
un moment merveilleux
nul doute que le maréchal de saxe
occupants du château entre 10 745 et
1750 et brillant stratège qui donna son
nom aux écuries de chambord n'aurait pas
été mécontent de voir les chevaux
réinvestir les lieux